[Music]
this solitary divine warship is at the
same time essentially the divine worship
of a community
and the pure inner knowing and
perceiving of itself advances to the
moment of consciousness
the contemplation of itself is its
objective existence
and this objective element is the
declaration of its knowing and willing
as something universal through this
declaration the self
acquires moral validity and the act
becomes an effective
deed the actuality and lasting existence
of what it does is universal
self-consciousness
but the declaration of conscience
affirms the certainty of itself to be
pure self
and thereby to be a universal self on
account of this utterance in which the
self is expressed and acknowledged as a
central being
the validity of the act is acknowledged
by others the spirit
and substance of their association are
thus the mutual assurance of their
conscientiousness
good intentions the rejoicing over this
mutual purity
and the refreshing of themselves in the
glory of knowing and uttering of
cherishing and fostering such an
excellent state of affairs
insofar as this conscience still
distinguishes its abstract consciousness
from its self-consciousness
it has only a hidden life in god it is
true that god is immediately present
in its mind and heart in itself but what
is manifest its actual consciousness
and the mediating movement of that
consciousness is for it something other
than that hidden inner life
and the immediacy of god's presence it
is only in the completed form of
conscience that the
distinction between its abstract
consciousness and its self-consciousness
is eliminated conscience knows that the
abstract consciousness is just this self
this being for itself that is certain of
itself knows that it is precisely in the
immediacy of the relation of the self
to the in itself which when posited
outside the self
is an abstract god and hidden from it
that the difference is eliminated
for that relation is a mediating one in
which the related terms are not
one and the same but each is an other
for the other and only in a third term
are they one
the immediate relation however means in
fact nothing else but the unity of the
terms
the consciousness that is risen above
the thoughtlessness that still holds
these differences
which are none to be differences knows
the immediacy of the presence within
itself of the absolute being
as the unity of that being and its own
self
it thus knows itself as the living in
itself and knows that this knowledge is
religion
which as knowledge that has a perceived
or outer existence
is the utterance of the community
concerning its own
spirit
paragraph 656 is one of these longish
paragraphs in which there's a lot going
on
and you could say that the feeling
the affectivity inhabiting it is is
somewhat of a triumphal nature we're
going to see
consciousness congratulating itself not
just by
itself but as an entire community
over all these wonderful things that it
has attained at this point in its
development
now whenever you see something like this
happening
for hegel you should always be
at this point in the phenomenology a
little bit skeptical about the
presentation
not skeptical necessarily about whether
hegel is getting things right
but about whether this actually
represents what
hegel thinks is happening and
whether the self-portrayal by
consciousness self-consciousness spirit
at this point in time
is is in fact true or whether it's
in some respect deceiving itself lying
to itself and that is definitely
the case here so for those who would you
know read this out of context
and say oh this is so wonderful solitary
divine worship divine worship of
a community uh jumping further down
we've achieved the absolute being as the
unity of that being in its own self
this is so amazing so wonderful you know
we've got god immediately present in
mind
none of that is actually what hegel
thinks
at bottom is really going on he is
presenting this
as he has in the previous paragraphs uh
and with so many other dialectics
to allow a shape of consciousness
to present itself its own self
portrayal in in in its fullness
so that afterwards he can say well
there's more to the story than this
and you know we can see that there are
oppositions and antithesis coming
out of this that undermine it that
show it to be hollow we're veering
eventually
towards the religion section hegel
mentions religion here
and we're also veering towards the end
of this morality section in which he's
going to accuse
this sort of consciousness that we find
in conscience
of being a mere beautiful soul being as
we
you know sometimes say here all talk and
no
do and talking or expression
as we saw in the previous paragraphs is
an absolutely essential
element of what's going on here
so all that said by way of preface so
that people don't think that
hegel is actually you know setting this
out
as sort of an end point it's sort of a
glorious achievement
for consciousness self-consciousness
spirit
but it's also one that rings hollow
rings
false let's take a look at the actual
text and at what's going on so
it starts out pretty good this solitary
divine worship which
solitary divine worship the one that was
just talked about in paragraph
655 where
uh the the the conscience is its own
self-divine worship its action is the
contemplation of its own divinity
saying that it is essentially god or god
like right the voice of conscience in
me as i take my stand that is the voice
of god
and how many people have been deluded by
their
own voices within well conscience
doesn't
worry about this at this point it is
convinced that it is
right and
it's going to be even more than that so
he goes uh
this is at the same time essentially the
divine worship of something more
what's more than the individual you
could say society
hegel doesn't use that term here instead
he brings up
a community a gominda
there's a contrast in german between
a community sort of like a local or
you know what hegel is earlier called an
ethical
community and then society gesellschaft
where you know things are more regulated
according to
norms that are above the board rather
than being regulated by
customs or habits zita and and you know
nor structures that have been replicated
over and over again and so we should see
this as
involving what hegel in earlier parts
was calling ethical
substance in in sections of the
phenomenology
found in the reason portion of the work
and earlier in the spirit portion of the
work this is an attempt to sort of
recuperate
this and bring it back in it's also i
think you should say
you know there's a lot of different
translations for this in the
phenomenology
hegel will talk about the zakazelpst
something that if you go back to
particularly the reason section
you're going to see him bringing up a
lot in terms of
moral or ethical comportments right so
in the sections like reason in the law
of the heart or
you know the section on virtue or reason
giving itself laws
what is it trying to do it's trying to
you know we can literally translate sock
as alps as the thing itself but but it
really means something like
the you know ethical project the
the main show so there's this this
back and forth between conscience the
conscience of the person
and an entire community and now this is
not just
with one individual although each
individual is portraying themselves this
way
there's multiple people and they
comprise this community and they do it
through this
divine worship i do want to say a little
bit about this term divine worship so
go to steenst in
german yes it can be translated as
divine worship
i think in this section you could also
talk about it as
the divine service and
you could say warship service aren't
they the same thing
yes although deinst deenan
this goes all the way back to the master
slave dialectic and to the
unhappy consciousness right where there
is this split
between the individual consciousness
and and god the divine and
one of the tragic things in the unhappy
consciousness is that the individual
who devalues him or herself in relation
to the divine the eternal
does not realize that they are actually
projecting that that it comes from them
and from their community and they they
lose sight of that in trying to worship
this this
divine other here the divine worship is
of the
conscience and of the community and you
could say well who's doing the the
worshiping who's doing the serving well
they're both
worshiping and and serving and being
worshiped and being
served and so he says
the pure inner knowing and perceiving of
itself
advances to the moment of consciousness
bevus sign he says and there's no
qualifier there it's not
self-consciousness it's just
consciousness so being aware of and then
he says the contemplation
of itself is its objective
existence and this objective element is
the declaration of its knowing and
willing as something universal that's
not something
really that new he's been saying that
throughout the thing conscience asserts
itself its own point of view as the one
that reflects a universal
knowing and willing now
is that really the case well that will
have to be seen
he goes on and he says through this
declaration
now declaration here is auschbrecken
right it's literally sort of like saying
out
saying onto right so so there's there's
an element
of the language there it's not just that
the actions are expressive it's not just
that we can peer inside
people's heads and see their knowing and
willing it is something that is being
said
i i my conscience this is what i am
doing
i do the act and then i also talk about
it for the people in my community
and they do the same thing and we're all
one big happy acting
family you could say or local community
so he says through this declaration the
self
acquires moral validity
okay that's that's interesting so
without
talking about itself this implies that
it can't really have complete moral
validity
it can't be entirely certain of itself
as a moral being
without talking about it there's another
thing he says right here as well that's
really interesting
the act becomes an effective deed
here are the terms that he's using
handling act
really should be translated action
becomes an effective
deed taught you could translate it as
the
action or the praxis becomes an
effective
act it is consolidated into
an act can be identified as such and
then he goes and says the actuality and
lasting existence of what it does
is universal now notice
self-consciousness universal
self-consciousness
but the declaration of conscience
affirms the certainty of itself to be
pure self and thereby to be a universal
self and this seems like it's
you know once again replicating this
dialectic
and even distinction unter sheed
right between the abstract universal
self
and actual existing particular
self-consciousness the person that i am
when i affirm
myself as acting rightly
because of conscience i am saying that i
am in some way
also this universal self but that's you
know kind of tough to pull off because
what if you do it too
you know what if the other members of my
community say no no you're
you're acting the wrong way my
conscience tells me something
different so there is this distinction
between this abstract
universal self and the the self that i
am
and but it's being overcome here he says
on account
of this utterance in which the self is
expressed
now notice and acknowledged as
essential being the validity of the act
is acknowledged
by others others in my
community other consciences other
self-consciousnesses who are the other
to me and i am the other to them
we're getting recognized we're getting
on our kant acknowledged recognized
we're getting what it is
that that consciousness and
self-consciousness have been looking for
this entire time since the struggle
uh the the moment of recognition
involved in the struggle to the death a
totally imperfect one and then the
master slave dialectic then the various
dialectics of self-consciousness then
all the things that happen in reason
and in spirit up till this point it
looks like we're finally getting what we
truly want a mutual
self-recognition that's consolidated in
a
way of life in a living community
so he goes on and he says here's where
it gets really interesting
the spirit and substance of their
association
are thus the mutual assurance of all
these different things now
we're going to we're going to talk about
that in a moment but first i want to
come back to this so in this interaction
between conscience and the
community through this this divine
warship of each other of themselves
and all of that all these great
reconciliations we have a sort of
focus on these four elements knowing
willing acting
and expressing auschbrecken he also uses
the term
reida you know which can be translated
in a number of different ways discourse
is is a good way to talk about it so
language is playing a central role here
and in addition to having recognition
now we actually also have what he calls
what he's translating miller here as
mutual assurance i think it's gegenz
right a being secure in something
so it's not just that i get recognition
from from you
and you you know get recognition from me
and that's
wonderful already we also get assurances
or
security from each other in this
you're you're a person of conscience i'm
a person of conscience we're in this
wonderful
community we're all so great together we
would never steal from each other
or slander each other or privilege our
own
over yours or cheat or do any of those
sorts of things we're all these
wonderful people together
isn't this marvelous and now
we can go on and talk about what the
again this is
quite important the spirit and
substance right it's rare that we have
these things actually
united in one thing right the spirit and
substance
of their association is
what the mutual assurance the the uh
being able to count on
a bunch of different things
conscientiousness
gevissen haftikeit is the word here
conscience right not it's not just
conscience each of us has a conscience
we've both got or we've all got
conscientiousness we're following
our consciences right good
intentions
right we can rely on everybody else
as having the right motivational
structure
the right prioritization of goods the
right
capacity to choose
you know good over evil over and over
again right all
these these things and intentions are we
should point out
it's just been talked about in the
previous paragraphs intentions are
inside of ourselves how do we know that
other people's intentions are good
we're we're relying on them actually
being expressed i i say i would never do
anything wrong
i i am only thinking of the common good
or what's best or you my dear friend
right and they're saying similar things
as well
mutual purity here he talks about
rejoicing over
mutual purity right um
vexil zeitgeist reinhardt is you know
the state of being pure uh the zeitgeist
uh sort of a there's an exchange the the
purity
reinforces each other's purity and then
here he says something really
interesting uh as he brings us to a
close
the refreshing of themselves in the
glory
the glory here is translating herely
kite and okay that makes sense to
translate it as glory
uh not only does miller do that um but
but others do as well
uh glory is is is you know what the lord
has
hair is lord so it could be understood
in terms of
the divine the goat right god
but it it can also be understood hare is
also the master
the master in the master slave dialectic
and all the things that go after the
master slave dialectic
into the other movements
of self-consciousness there's this
struggle with
both the human lord or master
and also the absolute master death
so hairless kite i'm not saying don't
translate it as glory i'm just saying
there's more of a resonance there
that should if you you know if you're
paying attention
there's something else being signified
here
now let's come back to it in the glory
of what
the glory of knowing
and uttering expressing talking
and now he says something else instead
of saying willing and acting
he brings up two other things things
that we could say well they are
in some respect acts and they are in
some respect
willing as well provided we understand
will
in a rather broad sense where it doesn't
just comprise
deliberate choices made at a particular
point in time between two
options but rather includes our
sort of general inclinations and
the structures of of our are willing our
heart
you could say so we look at it you might
say more augustinian
kind of sense so what else do we have
here we have
knowing and uttering cherishing and
fostering cherishing
isn't that an interesting thing to talk
about loving
and also fostering which is an action
thing as well
this wonderful state of affairs this
great
interaction between the community fully
realized people
all of this isn't this amazing
so that's
what is is being portrayed as
um what's been achieved now there's
another way he's talking about this as
well
he says insofar as his conscience still
distinguishes makes an
unteshed right separates out
these these uh two things
it's abstract consciousness from its
self-consciousness
it has only a hidden life in god
it's true god is immediately present in
its mind and heart
in itself but what is manifest is
actual consciousness and the mediating
movement of that consciousness
is for something other than that hidden
inner life and the immediacy of god's
presence and the question is can it
bring this then to
to light can it overcome this and here
hegel is saying
conscience thinks that it has done that
it succeeded
in that he says it's only in the
completed form of consciousness
the one that has been brought to its
fruition the one that has
completely been worked through which you
know conscience is portraying
itself to itself and to all the other
members of the community
as consciences as having now done this
whether or not that's a true claim is
yet to be seen
as it turns out it's going to be false
but it has i mean it has
in some respect i should take that back
it has brought itself to its fulfillment
to its completion it's just that its
completion
isn't what it takes it to be right this
is as good as it's going to get
for conscience and it's not going to be
as good as as it needs it to be to bring
the process to to an end
so he says the completed form of
conscience the distinction between
its abstract consciousness this abstract
universal self
and its self-consciousness winds up
being and here miller translated
as eliminated um
i mean you could say eliminated it's
it's alf haven
right so um we could also say sublated
transformed into something else uh
because it's not gonna it's not as if
it's
totally just effaced and left behind
entirely so he says conscience knows
that the abstract consciousness is just
this self
this being for itself that is certain of
itself knows that it is precisely
in the immediacy of the relation of the
self to the in itself
which when posited outside of the self
is an abstract god and hidden from it
that that's the unhappy consciousness
again or whatever else
we're making the divine and saying
that's not us
that's something else that's where the
the most important stuff is
now here conscience says i am actually
as who i am this individual i am also
the locus of divinity
in the the universe as is everybody else
in the community that we're all sharing
this
wonderful experience with but coming
back to
to the single person who's talking about
this he says that
um the relation is a mediating one
in which the related terms are not one
and the same but each is an other for
the other only in a third term are they
one
they're the immediate relation means in
fact nothing else but the unity of these
terms
so what's happening here consciousness
is making a conscience consciousness as
conscience is making itself
something where there's an immediate
unity
and a distinction is being effaced a
distinction is no longer being respected
but rather there's a i
am this going on in it
and he says the consciousness that has
risen above the thoughtlessness that
still holds these differences
which are none to be differences knows
the immediacy
of the presence within itself of now
here's where miller adds something in
the absolute being as the unity of that
being and its own self the german
doesn't actually have the
the absolute being he's reading that in
and i don't think that's really a
problem
provided we realize that this is
consciousness
in effect deceiving itself as conscience
telling itself that it's achieved much
more
than it has so it's telling itself that
it is
the unity of being veisen and
its own self and it is the living
in itself and knows then he says that
this knowledge is religion
which is knowledge that is a perceived
or outer existence is the utterance of
the community
concerning its own spirit so there's a
lot of the individual now speaking on
the part of the community using the
community as sort of an
amplifier to say i am this you know this
is what what
is going on i cannot be mistaken in the
moral stances that i take because my
knowing my willing my action
and my talking about it are not just
pure
or without sin or whatever you want to
put it right
they are the abstract self and the
individual self
unified now and i'm speaking for god
so when we put it like that i think you
might start to see
some of the points where an outside
observer
like hegel like a phenomenologist could
say
oh is that really the case they might
bring together to bear a kind of
socratic irony and say
really you think so that's that's
amazing
tell me more about this and you know the
socratic dialectic of
tell me more about this you know how
that works if you've read
the plato's dialogues there's always
some presentation of something
and bringing it into the light allows
you to see where the cracks are
where the flaws are to go around to the
back side and say
wait a second looks good from this side
this is all garbage here
and that is exactly where we're going to
be going with this so this this whole
thing
this whole you know wonderful
moment as as miller has it translated
here
the sort of mutual congratulation on
this excellent state of affairs
it is something that has been attained
at least in part
it's gone out there as an ideal for us
but it's not actually going to be
realized at this point despite
conscience
asserting that it is
you